en directo a nos vamos para chile para
hablar de cómo avanzan las
investigaciones en torno a los incendios
que en las últimas dos semanas se han
cobrado 25 vidas y han consumido más de
400.000 hectáreas saludo en este momento
a nuestra corresponsal en Santiago
Patricia Luna con quien Vamos a abordar
este tema Patricia un estudio del
gobierno señala que el 25% de estas
conflagraciones fueron intencionadas que
hay detrás de estas cifras
pues así él según un estudio de la
corporación nacional forestal uno de los
organismos que está en el terreno
combatiendo los incendios de 650
incendios investigados un 25,1% tendrían
una intencionalidad evaluando aspectos
técnicos haciendo una investigación
sobre el origen de estos incendios la
ministra del interior Carolina toja
afirmó en su último balance que sabemos
que hay intencionalidad en los incendios
y también que el 99,8% de estos
incendios tienen una causa humana pero
que también hay otros factores como
negligencia o Estados Temerarios en este
respecto la ministra también señaló que
existen en el país 39 detenidos por esta
causa la mayoría de ellos son por
neglicencias o por instruir en la labor
de extinción de las brigadas algo que
también se ha producido de forma aislada
en algunas ocasiones Y que solo una
pequeña minoría sería asociada a esta
intencionalidad de otra parte Patricia
ya este lunes llegó al país austral el
equipo de expertos italianos que
precisamente van a profundizar en estas
pesquisas
Así es el equipo ya se encuentra y ha
recorrido el
ñuble y el bío bío dos de las zonas más
afectadas están ahí para tratar de
asesorar tanto al ministerio público
como a carabineros se trata de un equipo
de expertos de los carabineros italianos
expertos en el origen de ese tipo de
siniestros que van a estar asesorando
técnicamente y también evaluando el
origen de estos fuegos que ha sido una
de los temas que más se ha hablado de
los que más se ha hablado también en los
medios y también por los habitantes de
la zona que cuando visitamos también
afirmaban que habían intencionalidad en
estos juegos porque en muchas ocasiones
aparecían varios focos a la vez será
determinante la ayuda de estos expertos
para poder establecer el origen de estos
incendios o qué parte tiene que ver la
intencionalidad además de otros factores
como las altas temperaturas
Los Altos vientos también y
las condiciones de humedad que en la
zona y que hacen que los focos se
reactiven y que los incendios sean
extendidos por más de dos semanas